new MBAs me ladies gonna get out and run
and you know the days of the half-court
game is kind of non-existent to get to
the playoffs the Walker Hornets forcing
a lot of mistakes again tonight
Walker fire Walker is dialed in six
finished and brought big changes a new
general management Mitch Kupchak as
Steve Clifford out his head coach James
Blair a go ins Kemba Walker discipline
name that tune this season four quarter
without friends second half of the year
that's the way it wasn't you know that
was clearly evident in Washington in the
fourth quarter
market is good three to shoot
not claim unless it's absolutely Esther
I'm sure he's thinking that what police
you own the spin cycle
we'll shoot me with a skip Kimmel
walking stop Soledad steps back watches
it go through team of the dream a large
one it's nice as joelle after really
starting off slow last year's are a
number of different reasons that isn't
that the case now for the blitz this
match here
Kemba long - for the captain second
field goal with the shoulder hook
we're in the Harlem Globetrotters came
on and do anything you to go anywhere
[Music]
[Applause]
Walker for a three wha a gigantic
three-pointer our home record is in
jeopardy you can feel his confidence
growing even on the road timba it's on
the run
Wayne bacon which is ejected at the game
for Petula Kemba the step back on
muscala he has been the shining light
for the Hornets here in the first
quarter
Tim Bob too long we saw the spot that he
needed to get to with the time here
did I count with the basketball Kim the
finally gets it step back and it goes
and then that kind of week for Kevin is
gonna absolutely up right where he left
off the other night lay this out hope
it's step back again shoot softly just
get it on the front and it'll fall in
canvas so Pratt to get treble bass line
[Applause]
difficult shot to pull up that quick
little hesitation freezes Turner
suburban st. that's what is a good
rhythms a bball gets the momentum open
this game up
you're right partner awesome look too
close and fill it to come for their last
ten shots defenses become the issue
Kemba a ballot step gets it to fall you
did some talk radio in your day I get so
that's a skill set man cuz it's not easy
to do is Walker knocks down that jumper
and the Hornets first field goal of the
second half can walk through the
container look for the three Brown try
the cheek 15 and 15
[Music]
Campbell Walker back-to-back pill gone
and on the right side of the rim he's
well put together for ya on the cross by
Walker and the highlight temple Walker
to shoot the ball just been first points
of the night for Dudley Walker Wow fake
jab fade Walker gets the roll he sizes
up the big guys Walker steps back behind
the line and trains another one Walker
just 2 of 5 shooting so far make that 3
of 6 this is about rebounding with five
guys attacking the glass
Amba hesitation move side steps and
connects fourth quarter Kemba
that was a step back and stayed to the
right that was a step back and stayed to
the right now it he made it look easy
that is a difficult shot right and if
you're the son the new ego you like okay